major news over the weekend about the
Dakota access pipeline we've talked
about the militarization of police at
the Dakota access pipeline we've talked
about protests by veterans there to uh
basically serve as human shields from
protesters we've talked about Donald
Trump's interest in going forward with
the pipeline as well as his financial
conflict of interest bia owning shares
in one of the involved companies and the
major news is that the Army Corps of
Engineers is not going to grant the
permit for the Dakota access pipeline to
drill under that Missouri River but this
was announced yesterday by the Army
Corps of Engineers and this is a major
win although possibly a temporary win
and I'll explain that a little bit as
well a major win for the Standing Rock
Sioux tribe and according to Joe Ellan
Darcy who's the assistant secretary for
civil works at the Army Corps of
Engineers she said quote although we
have had continuing discussion and
exchanges of new information with the
Standing Rock Sioux and Dakota access
it's clear that there's more work to do
and the best way to complete that work
responsibly and expeditiously is to
explore alternate routes for the
pipeline crossing so now the Army Corps
is going to undertake an environmental
impact statement they're going to look
for alternative routes this is the same
thing that the Standing Rock Sioux tribe
said in their own announcement so
victory in the short term absolutely
undeniable now Jan hasselman who's an
attorney for the tribe said number one
this is a decision that can be appealed
and number two this is uh a pipeline
that could just have a slightly
different route that is ultimately a
blue approved so I want to be clear Pat
this is a victory for now but we know
the incoming trump administration wants
to deregulate fossil fuels they up the
energy company involved will likely
appeal the decision it's not over till
it's over and Donald Trump up formally
announcing his support for the pipeline
a few days ago so but can we call it a
short-term win I absolutely would call
it a win and not just the win for this
tribe and for clean water but also just
in the political process when you have
this coalition of outsiders and insiders
made Americans and veterans all coming
together
you can you can enact political change
no doubt so I think that that is really
the big story here which is that we can
attribute some of this victory to the
recent arrival of veterans to protect
protesters we all know that the
headlines would be hugely damaging if
you see law enforcement treating vets
the same way that they were treating
protesters that would not play well and
we've also learned that protesting can
accomplish stuff when done number one
strategically number two with clear
goals but we also should learn from this
that just saying oh were protesting that
doesn't alone have the impact that many
people would want this succeeded because
it was knowing how to protest and stand
up for what's right it's because they
were building coalitions they were using
the law in their favor they had legal
representation that coincided with very
successful protesting from a media
optics point of view I think if there's
a lesson to be learned here for protest
activism Pat it's that you need to do
more than just the protesting they
really did it it was very strategically
done because if you saw some of the
tactics that the police were using it
was things like water hoses yeah and
sound cannons they didn't respond in
kind they responded peacefully and ended
it worked out well to their favor and I
know some people will say well but David
some of the protesters didn't respond
peacefully by and large they did and
that that that's uh part of the bigger
picture as to why this was successful so
no doubt a victory for now Dakota access
pipeline permit will not be granted as
designed we will watch for the appeal we
will watch for commentary from Donald
Trump and we will continue to keep you
up to date on the situation